I actually want to start with
um uh you did a video for Andrew Stanton
for the panel that we did at Comic-Con
you sent in a little thing and I just
wanted to say thank you
my pleasure you know I love and Andrew
he's uh great guy
um and a really terrific director I had
a good a really good time on on John
Carter it was a it's a great that's you
know what that that would be a good
study
when you look at you know people look at
all the successful films they go oh yeah
look at all these wonderful films that
did incredibly well it's like to look at
to to go back and look at films that did
not do well at a box office and say why
what what missed where did it Miss is
the story is it marketing is it too it's
interesting you say that because I've
had this conversation with people
specifically about John Carter the the
movie made actually almost 300 million
dollars globally but the problem is that
the film costs so much money to make
that it was not profitable but I've
heard people call that movie a bomb and
I'm like it made almost 300 million
dollars that's not a bomb it just didn't
make enough money and it gets that label
and then you can't shake the label it's
very frustrating I really enjoyed
Andrew's work on that but anyway I'll
tell you I'll tell you one more thing
that's frustrating to me when I was
young there used to be really good film
critics to come on the air during the
news and to tell you
artistically what they responded to what
they recommend you go see a tiny little
Art House movie or a big budget movie
whatever and somewhere in between they
gave you their artistic impression of of
and with a complete with with uh
relativity and and uh and and you then
made your decision now they fired all
those people and what they have instead
are the news readers the anchors reading
what the box office successes were for
the weekend as if the number the five
top box office numbers are that's a
recommendation to go see that movie
because it made that much money I will
say though I do I do think there are
some news people
um I think of some of the people in LA
and I know some reporters around the
country but it is not a position that is
as
um the way it was when I was younger and
you were younger yeah it's sad I totally
uh agree um uh I have to ask you I read
um and I have a lot of questions for you
but I read that you used to collect
baseball memorabilia and I wanted to
know do you still do that
you know I I never really did
um I had a big birthday
uh you know I'm a huge baseball fan and
uh I had a big birthday and for a lot of
the presents that came on this birthday
uh were memorabilia and so I was given
these gifts and it's like baseball cards
and baseballs and plaques and pictures
and things like that and baseball bats
and this so it's like oh my I have all
these things and I I put them on display
in my office and I did an interview and
I made a mistake of having the
interviewer come up to my office and he
looked around and he looked at all the
baseball memorabilia and he said you're
a collector and I said actually no I'm
really not I just got these as a present
but he forgot to put that part in and
said he's a major baseball
and so I would get hit up by people
saying hey I've got a you know a Hank
Greenberg card from 1924 and I got I I'm
really not a collector I'm not a
collector of anything really I don't
particularly like too many things that
that take up my shelves I know you do
look at you I was gonna say don't look
behind me please you've got all kinds of
things do you have my doll back there
the Walter White doll I I don't because
uh I don't uh I don't think they've made
a good enough version of it that I want
to have it behind me how dare you I'm
being honest with you I think that if
Sideshow Collectibles hot toys they make
a super hot like great one I listen I I
love uh I love that show and I love your
performance on that show and I would be
happy to add it behind me
um so um I definitely have to ask you I
I know you are offered a bunch of
scripts and projects what was it about
uh Jerry and Marge that said I need to
do this it was during lockdown during
the covid lockdown and several months
into it
I was feeling restricted and and and
disconnected from people and because of
that it was created sort of an
anti-social environment
and I thought I want something to make
me feel better and I read this script
and it and I put it aside I go that's
really cute I really liked it it's a
true story okay I read another one I put
I go I don't know about that it's kind
of dark and I look back at Jerry and
Marge and I went I kept looking back at
Jerry and Marge and that's always a good
sign if I keep thinking about something
it that it's starting to enter my
subconscious and you know I just thought
why not do something that lifts the
spirits of people and and I to this day
I say you know Jerry and Marge Go Large
will not change your life but it can
change your day and there's value to
that
yeah when I when I watched it it was
what I wanted just like a feel-good you
know like great actors just it was a
feel-good movie and I I wanted it and uh
it was I really enjoyed that exactly
what you're saying yeah thanks Steve
um so I have to ask listen I know you
are a tremendous actor when you were
playing someone uh you know who's real
uh like a real portrayal do you feel
more pressure on yourself to try to you
know um bring that person to life or do
you sort of accept that this is a movie
where you know what I mean like I'm
gonna have a little I have freedom to do
what I want with non-fictional
characters there comes an additional
responsibility absolutely I do whether I
played Dalton Trumbo or Lyndon Johnson
uh those family members are still alive
these men did something of note and and
I want their their friends and family
who who remember them to uh to say oh he
got him he he got him he got the essence
of him so you know I'm playing Jerry
Selby and he's not famous and I told him
I'm not doing impersonation I'm I might
even change your personality a little
bit and I did he is a very gregarious uh
fun guy he'll speak to anyone he'll talk
to he's very outgoing and I thought I
think my Jerry Selby would be better for
the movie in our little hour and a half
to make him a little more reticent a
little more
um
softer and and not as outgoing you know
and and so I I I took that tone and
Annette took a tone of of a little more
assertiveness and I thought oh that's
good and we talked about it and and I
think it Blended and complemented each
other absolutely and I listen I I always
think that um the real stories there the
movie it needs to be a movie you know I
I I think sometimes people forget that
but
um so I I'm a huge Wes Anderson fan and
I loved your work in Isle of dogs and it
was a voice over work and did you when
you were voicing it did you think to
yourself maybe I'll finally get the call
for Live Action
I did you're absolutely right Steve
there's no question about it when you
when you work with for an auteur like
that
um it is a big trust exercise and and uh
we did this movie coming up asteroid
City in Spain and it was it wasn't easy
work working for Wes is not easy it's
very detailed and very specific and so
you really have to really concentrate
hard
what offsets that is the Congeniality uh
and and the the togetherness of the
experience so we're all at this
five-star hotel in Spain and every
single night is a banquet every single
night you're exchanging thoughts and
laughter and someone brings a guitar and
you're singing and you're doing it's
just uh it it's just so familial it's
it's like fulfilling an actor Dream Camp
you know it's like with it's just it's
it's really it was a really really great
experience albeit again the work was
very specific and very and very
difficult were you when he finally
called you or texted you wherever you
got the information where you finally
like were you like finally
yeah you know and when someone like that
calls you know it's the same thing I I
did the same thing with with Tom Hanks
when he called for something it's like
yes and what am I doing so I say to Wes
Anderson yes uh what what is it you want
me to do you know and that's the way it
is for all the actors we kind of show up
and say what is it you want us how do
you want us to do this Wes makes a uh an
animatic and voices all the characters
in The animatic what he calls the
cartoon and he hands us he gets us the
and we so we watch it on a laptop when
we watch the entire movie that he voices
on a laptop and it's like oh got it I
see where you're going I see what you're
doing and let me see if I can hit that
Target the character you've already
created let me see if I can point my
arrow toward it and hit it Bullseye my
last question for you because I'm just
about out of time like I said at the
beginning I really am a big fan of your
work and I'm just curious if you have
like a big emotional scene on a Monday
morning something that you know will
challenge you
um how early on are you actually
preparing for that moment if it's like a
day you have circled in your calendar
you know it's a tough day
um are you like is it weeks out you're
thinking about it like could you sort of
maybe just tell me how you like to prep
um well that's that's true how you
you're talking about it we you look
ahead when you're doing a movie you look
ahead and you and you kind of gauge
where your tough days are where your
easy days are and you you can monitor
your your energy output and you can also
start to start to lean in and focus on
those on those days and how you want it
to how you hope it will turn and
um
you know it depends on the complexity of
the scene
uh it depends you know how long you have
to really focus on it sometimes you get
a character and you go I know exactly
what I want to do and you lean into that
others it's like it's still kind of
outside of me and I'm not quite sure
until I'm on the set and working with
the other actors to figure out how it's
going to come and you just have to give
in to that ambiguity and that
unknowingness that and trust that it
will come because your interest and
desire and and your experience and
talent is there and you're going to pull
it out you'll get it you'll get to it it
you know but you can't you can't always
design how it's going to come it's never
never really a point A to point B kind
of Journey it takes its own tour
sometime and you're trying to figure out
how oh we're on track Jesus that was
interesting I know you get off track and
you get back on track and
and it's bits and pieces and they will
end up cutting the the parts out that
were off track and you're like oh got it
oh this that that works well
um on that note I appreciate that answer
I really appreciate your time today and
I wish you nothing but the best and uh
you know thank you for all the years of
entertainment thank you Steve we'll talk
to you again